en una empresa que se llama ipsos que
tiene una agencia en francia que hizo un
estudio a profundidad donde decía que el
poder adquisitivo y la seguridad social
eran los dos factores clave para estas
elecciones presidenciales lo dijo desde
hace semanas atrás entonces por ahí es
que vimos a una imagen de la penn
enfocada justo como bien lo dice es la
parte laboral la parte de esta crítica
al girar de lo que sucedió en las
medidas que tomó emana el marco desde la
cuestión del alza de los combustibles de
ahí que fue el tema de los chalecos
amarillos que en su momento en el 2018
2019 se dijo que estaba ma jin depende
atrás de ese movimiento algo que no se
han podido comprobar el tema sin duda
del alza de la edad de la pensión es un
es un tema que está en la agenda de los
franceses es un tema que preocupa y de
ahí que también vimos a una imagen del
pene enfocada totalmente a
disminuir los impuestos sobre todo a los
jóvenes de 30 años trabajo cuando
mencionaba ella que iba a bajar los
impuestos sobre todo sobre la renta
porque le hablo tanto a los jóvenes no
olvidemos
el auditorio de 24 que el voto de los
jóvenes hoy en francia pueden pactar la
gran diferencia entre un candidato y
otro jóvenes que inclusive el 21 por
ciento principalmente en voto por el
tercer candidato que vimos a jean-luc
mélenchon en la primera vuelta y que se
se publicó esa base electoral a la cual
hoy los dos quieren cautivar porque hay
esto lo que va a ser claro y contundente
para el próximo domingo entonces sin
duda estos dos factores los errores en
el pasado de estos cinco años de manuel
marco fueron los puntos donde ella tenía
justamente que darle el revés pero ahí
es donde vimos que él estuvo pues
defendiéndose y argumentando en
cualquiera estas decisiones y pues
retomó el punto de mi participación
inicial las medidas que ella se está
enfocando es aumentar la deuda y el
gasto público mientras que el manuel
marco con su experiencia de haber estado
ya antes en un ministerio de economía en
ese país pues le permite saber hacia
dónde y ya sé a dónde maneja este tema
de las medidas económicas porque ojo
francia se enfrenta a una pandemia pero
también se enfrenta a las consecuencias
de la aplicación de sanciones dirigidas
a rusia donde este estrangulamiento
hacia esa economía ha impactado a nivel
mundial entonces de ahí que no podemos
perder de vista que lo que se está
viviendo el interior de francia se vive
en el interior de cualquier país en
colombia en méxico en todo el mundo lo
vivimos y no nada más tienen que ver con
un efecto negativo o positivo por
medidas de políticas públicas manejadas
en la actual administración sino que
también estas variables externas están
impactando en lo que se está viviendo al
interior de francia y por lo tanto
esperamos que los ciudadanos francesas
así lo consideren porque tampoco hay
fórmula mágica que lo vaya a revertir